-For those who don't know
your back story,
you were elected into Congress
in 2018.
You're one of the first
two Muslim women in Congress
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And first Palestinian-American.
-First Palestinian-America
woman.
And what was it like entering --
How have you found it so far
-I mean, it's interesting.
It's kind of
a love/hate relationship.
But my residents keep me
grounded and remind me every day
why I have to keep going there
and fighting for them.
So it's a very humbling
experience, as well.
You should see some of the early
footage of me coming out.
I was doing these selfies,
and I was super-excited.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I'm a congressmember."
I was like,
"How did this happen?"
You know, I didn't speak English
when I started school.
And my parents --
My mom only went up
to eighth-grade education.
My dad, fourth-grade education
And, you know, what's incredible
about this American story
is that they're a predominantl
non-Muslim community.
Fellow Americans who didn'
share my faith or ethnicit
elected me,
and that's the part of the story
I wish people
would know more about.
And I think it's just so much --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so much light
during this really dark time
in our country right now.
-We were talking backstage
8 and 13, your boys?
-Yes.
-And how are they taking t
having a congresswoman
for a mother?
-It's amazing. You should know
My son Adam is 13.
And he's --
He's like my policy adviser.
He literally -- He watches
my committee hearings.
-Oh, wow.
-And, yeah, he goes,
"Mom, how come you guys
didn't pass that amendment?"
And it's crazy. And he
also goes, "How's Maxine?"
I said, "Honey, that's
Chairwoman Waters to you."
Don't -- I know. It's crazy.
But I love it.
And my 8-year-old, you know,
I love that I'm just Mom
when I get home.
And, again, it just keeps me
humble, keeps me grounded.
-So I want to talk about this.
We've had you booked for months.
We've been very excited
about it.
And we were talking backstage.
You've had a crazy day.
-Yes.
-You did a podcast.
When did you actually
record the podcast?
-Last week.
-Okay, so, it came out.
And a lot of people
have been talking about it
both sides of the aisle.
You were talking about
the tragedy of the Holocaust
and you -- The words you use
was it gave you
a calming feeling
because you were happy
that it became a safe haven --
Palestine became a safe have
for the Jewish people.
Some criticized the use
of "calming feeling."
You have said
it was taken out of context.
I want to give you a chanc
to provide some context.
-Yeah, and, you know,
for folks that don't know,
I mean, my grandmother --
my living grandmother,
my mom's mom --
lives in the West Bank
in occupied territories
of Palestine.
And what's incredibly --
You know,
the tragedy of the Holocaust -
I mean, the reason
why Israel was created
was to create a safe haven
for Jews around the world.
And there is something,
in many ways, beautiful
about that my ancestors --
many had died or had to give u
their livelihood,
their human dignity
to provide a safe haven
for Jews in our world.
And that is something
I wanted to recognize
and kind of honor
in some sort of way.
But I also think it's importan
because I want the Palestinian
people also to find
some sort of, you know, light in
this kind of what's happening.
But also, you know, in the end
I said I want all of us
to feel safe.
All of us deserve human dignity,
no matter our backgrounds,
no matter our ethnicity,
no matter even our
political opinions.
We all deserve that kind
of equality and justice.
And, you know, for me,
I wanted to uplift that
and bring that to light.
And it was unfortunate.
You know, I got a text message
from a friend who's like,
"Hey, next time,
you know, really clarify.
Maybe talk like a fourth grader.
Because maybe the racist idiot
would understand you better.
So it's just -
You know, I will continue
to speak truth to power
and continue to uplift
my grandmother through love.
And that's all I can do,
is continue to share
the human impact of
what it means to be Palestinia
in the occupied territories.
-You know, I'm --
You know it's nice, I think,
to have someone in Congress as a
Palestinian who has a platform
because obviously it's never -
it happens very rarely.
Certainly in the media you don't
get the Palestinian perspective.
It does -- I actually thin
it wouldn't hurt for all of us
to talk about the history
of that part of the world
on a fourth-grade level
because I actually don't think
a lot of us here understand it
And I think that there's -
A very, very bad-faith argumen
was made today that you were
calmed by the Holocaust.
-Of course.
-I think there was
a good-faith argument
that maybe your history
did not --
was not in alignment
with everyone else.
And, I mean, do you feel lik
there's a way to talk
about the history
of that part of the world
that people here in this country
that maybe
don't fully understand it
could grasp it more?
-Absolutely.
I mean, I think, for me,
I grew up in the most beautifu
blackest city in the world
in the country,
which is city of Detroit.
And every corner is a reminder
of the Civil Rights Movement
And I, through my
African-American teachers --
You know, I call my black
mothers on the block
I grew up in --
They, you know, constantly tol
me about the pain of oppression.
They taught me
about the history of segregation
and feeling less than
and dehumanized
because they were black
in America.
And a lot of that, that lens
that I bring to this issue -
And that's how I talk about it
the fact that, you know,
we are dehumanizing a whol
community to uplift others
But I don't think that's truly
going to keep anybody safe
It's truly not going to lead
towards peace and equality
and justice.
And you have to,
when you look at this issue,
come from a place of values.
You know, people want to g
ahead and jump and choose sides.
No, come from a place of value
because, by the end,
you will choose the right side
of history when you do that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You mentioned --
You mentioned your distric
and obviously the things -
You know, you're getting
attention today for sort o
international affairs.
But you also have to take care
of your district at home.
Poverty's a very serious issue
at home.
How are you addressing tha
back in Michigan's 13th?
-Yeah, and the 13th
Congressional District
knows I always have their back
They taught me to be
unapologetically, you know
myself in
speaking truth to power.
But they come first.
You know, I have four
neighborhood service centers
where getting people through
everyday issues has to go
hand in hand
with the policy work.
And, you know, the challenge
around economic oppression
in many ways is something
that they can't wait
for me to pass a bill.
So I need to be able
to pick up the phone,
use the power of the letterhead.
You know, just the last --
A couple weeks ago,
a woman who's hearing-impaired
needed her Social Security
benefits,
and it took one phone call
for us to call,
and we found out it was
an administrative error
on the part of the Social
Security Administration.
And we got her $38,000, Seth
And, to me, I was like,
"Oh. This is why I'm here.
I want to change people's live
today.
They shouldn't wait years for us
to pass Medicare for all,
you know, minimum-wage increase,
and all the things that I thin
are critically important
in our country right now.